power to me and I think power
historically has been the ability to get
others to do something they don't want
to do it's a political and psychological
relationship it's using carrots and
sticks to create an impression in
someone's mind of what you can do to
help them or to harm them it's about
pressure and coercion
effective foreign policy really comes
down to common sense it's understanding
what's attainable what your power can
produce and what's not attainable it's
understanding how to use your power
because you understand just what power
you do have and how it's going to affect
other societies and other political
leaders some things that Americans
rarely understand so it comes down to
common sense judgment in international
relations it puts you on the mountain
and if you have the most power at the
top of the mountain but it also should
give you responsibility if you have
power because you have the power to get
things done solve problems that's an
awesome responsibility